you love solving mysteries was this
something that you were when you were a
kid did you want to solve mysteries I
when I was a kid I've always been really
obsessed with Columbo Columbo the TV
detective yeah I think we have a picture
of colombia's Peter Pham I just beep
initio del toro del Toro
as Columbo Benicio is see can't play so
many parts I've never heard of a little
girl wanting to be Columbo in the
raincoat and the cigar and I you know
what I mean you think of little girls
and this is incredibly sexist of me but
you the classic as though you want to be
Nancy Drew the the girl detective not no
I wanted to I I so I wanted to be
Columbo in fact when I was in second
grade I did a book report I don't know
what a book report was on like what
little kids like it was on like
left-handed scissors or something and I
dressed up as Columbo to do the report
like I came to school in a trench coat
and I pretended to Pat my pocket to not
and and not know where my note were and
I think I asked my teacher for a light
for my cigar it's that's very bizarre
behavior for a little girl it seems
perfectly normal to me yeah and so so so
so this has been like a lifelong passion
of yours and now that you have this
series and it's beginning it's becoming
very popular you get people pitching you
all the time can you solve this mystery
I mean really mundane mysteries but they
want to know there's a piggy bank I had
when I was a kid can you find out what
the expression on its face meant and you
have to actually figure that I just made
that one up that's why we don't really
like something did maybe some that in
and now I know it was from you yeah yeah
yeah people are sending me mister I'm
getting flooded with mysteries and I
feel like my show is all it's about
these everyday mysteries and I think
people are taking that very literally
yeah like one person one person wrote in
and said I don't understand what's going
on I put two pairs of socks in the dryer
and when it comes out there's only one
pair of socks
and I was like surely this is gonna be
the only person you census in but I got
like three people suggesting what
happens to socks yes watch them and then
another person said they went to Target
they buy all these gritty ball this
stuff including a candy bar and then
they put all the facade I'll go through
the checkout line they thought go in the
bag and when they got home the candy bar
wasn't in the back and they want me to
help them sell it's not a mystery that's
getting stupid now you probably have to
sift through so many ones there's some
good mysteries in there they're like
intriguing and your podcast has these
really great mysteries but the ones
you're describing or people lost it
cashier didn't put it in that happens
every day I know well they did say no we
thought go in the bag and I don't know
what happened and I feel like the thing
if I can't take I have to be able to
solve the mystery but they can't be too
easy to solve and that one I feel like I
can solve it right now like right here I
could do it's between the wedge between
the passenger seat in the cup holder
yeah that's right it's like someone
saying like there was a squirrel in my
backyard yesterday I don't see it today
figure it out
what are you supposed to do I can't they
want me to do their errands